Thanks for coming.
Hello? Anybody out there? You can talk back? No. Okay.
Uh, I'm glad you guys are all here. Thanks for coming.
Uh, I don't know that.
Do we have enough copies for everybody?
Did everybody get a copy? Or at least
to all the couples at least get a copy?
Um, I'm gonna start with the mic just
to save my voice a little bit.
If I can go without, that's fine too.
But, um, anyway, glad you guys are here.
So the only, my only problem is
that I gave away all the copies.
Did I have one of, uh,
I need the, uh, the al outline, the syllabus.
I don't have this. Oh yeah. Could I have one, one of those?
Anybody need the notes? Notes, Mr.
Bar extra note, borrow that. I'll give it back.
Alright, so welcome to Systematic Theology one.
It's number one, because that's
what we're doing this semester
and the systematic theology two will be next semester.
And so we'll talk about that a little bit.
But let's do this. Um,
before we start, let me pray for us and we'll die down.
Almighty God, we thank you for tonight.
And Lord, we thank you for the chance to be able
to gather together as your people in this place,
to study your word indeed, to, to think
the most incredible thoughts that could pass
through the mind of people, which is thoughts about God.
And we thank you that you have revealed yourself.
You have spoken through your word,
you've entered into this world through the coming,
first coming, and the incarnation of the Lord Jesus.
And we thank you that you want to be known by us
and uh, and that we have your word.
That is a faithful, reliable guy.
And I pray, Lord, as we just introduce the topic tonight,
as we proceed in the months ahead,
they indeed you would speak to us,
that you would open our eyes
to behold wonderful things in your word,
Lord, even more than that.
That we would see you in all of your glory and power
and majesty, and that we would love you more,
that we would worship you in truth,
and that we would rightly represent you
to the world around us.
So Father, we thank you
and uh, we give you our time tonight.
In Jesus name. Amen.
Alright, so, uh, if you've got a copy of the syllabus
or the outline for systematic theology one, I just wanted
to walk through that quickly.
Um, just a little housekeeping also as we go along,
if you can please sign up, uh, either when you come in
or on your way out, give us your
number, email, whatever it is.
Uh, if you don't have a copy,
I don't know if we ran out totally.
But if you don't have a copy of the outline
or the syllabus, if you would please
make sure we have your email.
And then I'll send out a copy of the notes with probably
with filled in answers in case you miss any of it, as well
as, um, the syllabus
and the outline in case you need that as well.
And if you have any other questions, uh,
you can contact David.
No, I'm just kidding you contact me.
But David's helping me out with all the logistics.
So thank you, David. We got us here thus far.
Um, okay, so, uh,
on the syllabus outline,
I just wanna go over this quickly just to kind
of highlight what we're doing.
Part of what we're doing tonight is just introducing the
topic and the subject
and, uh, the nature of the class as we walk through.
And so, uh, so just to begin with,
come on in this course.
As you may already know, uh, it's the first of a series,
well, I already said this, of two classes on this subject.
Systematic theology just,
or follows an organized approach to, uh, considering all
that God has said in his Word.
So you can read through this, the details of, um,
the course objectives.
We want. We want to deepen our faith.
We wanna cultivate a more consistent, coherent,
biblical worldview.
Uh, we also want to value the word
of God as the basis for all.
We believe we wanna, uh, implement the truth
of God's word into our lives.
And so it's a matter of knowing and being and doing.
And these are all things that we want to emphasize.
And, uh, and if you don't know already,
so I'm teaching tonight, I'm scheduled
to teach the last class,
and then also we've got a number of the elders who are here
and some who aren't, who are gonna be teaching some
of the individual classes as we go along.
So we're glad you guys are here,
and thanks for teaching the word to us as well.
And so, um, anyway, look forward to that as we go along.
The course textbook is, uh, this book right here,
you made some of you, I know we're familiar with this book,
Wayne Gru's, systematic Theology.
Anybody here got this or read this one?
Is this holding down paper on anybody's desk? Yeah.
So this is great.
This is a great resource, uh,
and I want to recommend you get a copy, have it refer, uh,
refer to it, uh, often,
but that's not the one we're primarily using tonight.
In this class, we're using the, he's got three of these,
and they're pretty much all the same.
The other one, you may have seen this basic Christian Doc,
Christian Beliefs, and uh,
it's the short version, cliff Notes.
This one's the mid range copy.
What we're planning to do in this class is do half
of this this semester
and then the back half of it next semester.
And so this is the class textbook.
I think I've got like 10 of them. What, how many do we got?
10, 20. How many do we get? I can't remember.
Um, I think it's 10. So anyway, they are
for sale through the church.
If you need one, I think they're $22.
If not, you can get an Amazon Christian book.
You can do Audible, you can do Kindle, you can probably, uh,
borrow one, right?
I mean, they're, they're out there. So anyhow, uh,
this second edition, and, uh, both
of these in fact are second edition.
And so if you got the old one, that works too.
But the page numbers are off.
And so, just so you know, anyway,
there's a, a list of books here.
I'm on page three. Uh, so
that's our required read if you wanna, I mean,
so you can attend this class
and not do any of the reading, uh, if, well,
so there's two things going on here, which you may know.
So you can just come, you can just come and, uh,
and you can attend the class as often as you're able.
You can follow along with the reading,
you can read the short book
or the mid book or the long book.
Uh, you can do whatever. You can knock yourself out.
Um, there's also going on a class
that is seminary students taking this for credit.
And so they have, they, it's not optional, right, for them.
So they've got to do the reading, they've got writing, uh,
all kinds of assignments that they have to do,
and they're gonna do all the
sweat, blood, and tears on that.
And so I think currently we have nine
that are seminary students enrolled for that.
That's through Midwestern Seminaries Spur College.
And, um, anyway, so if
that's something you're interested in,
you hadn't heard about that
and you don't know about that yet,
and you'd like to learn about that
or even do that, then, uh, please let me know.
You can earn up to like 33% of a master's degree that way.
And, uh, for free, other than just buying
the books and reading it.
So anyway, uh, there's a different syllabus for that.
If you're in that class, I was, if you're able, I'd like
to huddle after we're done
and just talk about that for, you know, a few minutes.
And I've got your syllabus
that we can go over if you've got questions on that.
But anyway, um, so there's a, I I've listed a bunch
of books in, uh, they're recommended for further study,
but, uh, if you're in the class,
these are required readings, at least one of them.
Uh, but I want to, we'll highlight them as we go along.
One's called the Lighting and the Trinity is a book review
that, uh, the students in that class will be doing.
And then also, uh, this one, finding the Right Hills
to Die on by Gavin Orland is another one for review.
And so I just wanna recommend, there's a lot
of different resources we could talk about.
And I even debated, you know, which books to use.
And so anyway, there's a, there are a lot
of good guides out there, but this is
what we're doing for this semester.
So, um, if you wanna look at the, uh, page four,
this is the schedule.
I've tried to just map it out.
This pretty much as follows
and maps over, uh, all the other classes
that are going on on Wednesday nights.
And so whenever all the classes are meeting this class would
will be meeting, um, if you're in the four credit class,
we've got a couple of additional things,
um, outside of that.
Otherwise, we are, everything is tied to
what everybody else is doing on Wednesday nights.
So that is what I have for us in that regard.
Uh, is there, do you have any questions about that outline
and syllabus at this point?
Any questions about that? Okay.
Either I did good
or, um, that was, you're totally lost,
so I'm gonna believe I did good and we'll move on.
Okay. Uh, so if you're interested in a
textbook, I've got, I think it is eight
or 10 of them left, I believe it is.
Uh, just grab me afterwards.
I know one's already spoken for, uh, paid for, and, uh,
and so anyway, uh, otherwise you can have the other ones.
Um, gosh, I meant to do this here.
Here's something I'm gonna do.
This is, uh, you
guys will help me pass this out.
Yeah. You know what?
I, one you don't remember, I do,
but you know, I'm, I'll hand it out in a minute.
Secret things. So, uh, what we're gonna do is pass those.
I'm, I'm sort of thinking through, like each night
we'll have, you could consider it a memory verse, like one
that you memorized, uh, meditate on, you try to commit it
to memory, but you talk about why that's valuable, if
that's something you've never done.
But the main thing I wanna do
with it is it's at least a kind of a key verse.
Like, it's a key verse that will sort of be thinking
through, or it's at least tied to the theme of
what we'll do for the evening.
And so anyway, um, if you've never seen something like this
before, I dunno if you've been in these classes,
we've done this on the front.
I've just got the verse written out on the back.
It's got the first letter of each word in that verse,
and it's just a tool to where as you get familiar
with the verse, you just repeat it.
And it's kind of a cheat sheet in that regard.
It's just a great aid to memory.
And so the main point is to, uh, if you wanna take it home,
stick it in your Bible, you know, put it on a,
on your refrigerator, whatever it is,
and, and think about it.
That's the whole point. Think about it.
We meditate on God's word.
It's a little like the way a cow chews the C, right?
Like, we wanna read it.
Sometimes we'll read it and we say, man, I'm there.
I've already read it. We really actually think about it,
and we stew over it, and we think about what it means.
We think about the words, and we let it seep into our minds
and our hearts and changes.
And so, uh, anyway, so I wanted to give that out.
We will, um, be talking about this verse, uh, we'll refer
to it a number of times tonight,
but let me begin by, uh, just reading it,
and then that'll be sent kind of the theme
for our, our evening.
So it comes from Deuteronomy 29, 29.
It's the beginning of that verse.
There's a little more to it,
but to save room, I just stopped there.
Um, and so Deuteronomy 29 29 says
that the secret things belong to the Lord our God,
but the things that are revealed belong to us
and to our children forever.
Now, this is an awesome passage of scripture.
In fact, if you've never, never memorized much,
I would recommend that you start here, uh, in the middle
of the Book of Moses, a book
that sometimes I think we feel like could be obscure.
Seems like a long time ago, uh, you know,
when King David wrote in Psalm on 19 said, oh,
how I love your law.
It is my meditation all day long.
He was literally thinking probably about the first five
books of the Bible, because God's law, the Torah was, uh,
the books of Moses, Genesis, Exodus, Leviticus,
Deuteronomy numbers, and, uh, anyway.
And so the secret things, so
what we're talking about here is there are
secret things, right?
Like he probably questions about God.
He probably thought about God
and even wondered at times, like,
like, I don't know about that.
You know? I mean, I don't know about you guys,
but I know the elders have, right?
You guys do that sometimes. Okay? Yeah. I, me too, right?
Even still, you know, I've been Christian, I've been,
I've been a Christian now for
like, I don't know how old am I?
Um, 25 plus years, I think,
uh, no, it's more than that.
Close to 30. And uh,
and I've found a lot of great answers over the time
and God's word and things that really help
and change my life and change my thinking.
But the truth is, I still have have thoughts about God.
I wonder about this, and I wonder about that.
And that's sort of why we wanna study a topic like this.
'cause what we realize, some of those things are secret
unless or until God makes them known.
That's the whole point of the word revelation in the sense
of like, God's not the book of Revelation, but e exactly.
But the sense of God revealing himself,
things we don't know about God
unless he makes it known to us.
And so anyway, there's secret things. They belong to God.
There's some things God will never tell us.
Some things we'll never fully understand.
But there are things that God has made known,
and these are the second part of this is that,
but the things that are revealed, the things
that God has made known to us, those
really matter to us.
What's it say there? They belong to us
and they belong to our children forever.
And so when I read a verse like that, I think, man,
there's awesome things about God
that I wouldn't otherwise know.
But he has made it known really clear and plain,
and he really wants us to know and understand those things.
And he wants us to so live in light of them,
that it changes us, and that we pass it on to our children
and to our children's children,
and from generation to the next
cross cultures across the whole face of this planet,
that the knowledge of God will be made known,
the things he's made known He wants us to know
and everybody else to know.
And so we need to explore them and pursue them.
That's why this is the theme verse.
Who do I steal this from? You can have it back.
Anybody you want one need it.
It's right up here, uh, on your way out.
So, uh, okay. Amen. Amen.
Alright, you can talk back to me as we go along.
Uh, just stop me about some things, okay?
Uh, so according to your notes,
if you wanna just start following along,
there's a lot to do here.
And my phone's right there, so, uh, I don't have a clock.
So David, if you'll be my clock,
I know we're talking about the m uh,
but if I'm running late, just lemme know.
Uh, what is theology?
What does that word, everybody here
heard that word for theology.
So we want to know what it means.
Where does that actually come from? Anybody know?
It's kind of a weird word. Theology. Theology.
So it's actually a combination of two
Greek words should have tried this.
First Theos
and Lagos,
God and word.
So these are two Greek words
they ask means God.
Lagos means word.
So we're, we're talking about God,
these are words about God.
And so informally, you might
just say, there's just God talk.
We're just talking about God. Like
what God, what's God like?
Uh, what are his, what's his nature?
What's his characteristics? What does he do?
Uh, maybe you hear this phrase sometimes out in the
world, maybe you've said it.
Say, well, my God would never do something like this.
Well, or somebody says, Hey, there is no God in some regard,
all of that is theological language.
It's common about it's words about God.
So, um, that's sort
of informally speaking in my sense that way.
Now, if you press that too far,
and someone says, well, my God would never do this.
Like, and it's clear in the Bible, he might
then we're guilty of something called idolatry,
which means we're making a God on our own image.
So we have thoughts about God, we have God's word,
we have other people's opinions,
but we still have, um, we're talking about God.
So informally, theology is just talking about God,
technically speaking kind of as a technical phrase.
It means, uh, the study of God.
So we're studying about God,
and even more formally than that, as we'll see in a minute.
Um, there's a specific category of theology broadly
that is called the doctrine of God.
Like where we're just talking about the nature
of not just everything God's revealed,
but the nature of God himself.
We call that specifically, we'll call it theology proper.
But anyway, um,
so there's theology which we're talking about, God.
So the the idea of systematic theology is
that there is a systematic approach.
It's not random or arbitrary.
It's not accidental or incidental.
Like, like I think theologically,
whenever I think, oh, I just wonder about this thing
where I have a problem in my life
where I encounter a question, I'm thinking about God,
I'm kind of doing theology about that.
But systematic theology is designed to be intentional
and focused and not just sort of scattered and random.
Um, and, and the thing that,
that thinking systematically about theology, part
of what's important about that is it makes sure
that we are able to sort of properly consider all
of the significant things that've got has revealed to us.
And so it's important that we think, uh,
systematically through that.
And that's what we try to do in, uh, systematic theology.
So obviously, like in this class,
and we're talking about, we're talking about Christian
theology, of course,
you can talk about theology from a Islamic standpoint
or from an atheist standpoint or a Buddhist standpoint.
And we're not doing any,
we're not talking about any of that.
We're talking about Christian theology,
meaning we're grounding it in the word of God.
We're talking about what God has made clear in
his word in the Bible.
And, uh, so in the textbook, Wayne Grum, the author,
he defines Theo Sy, he defines systematic theology this way.
It is any study that answers the question,
what does the whole Bible teach us today
about any given topic?
And obviously, as you probably know, if you're familiar
with the Bible, it doesn't address everything.
Like, for example, as I understand, I don't believe
that there are cats in the Bible,
but it doesn't mean they don't exist.
It doesn't mean that you may or may not like them, right?
Whatever it might be. But,
so God doesn't comment on everything,
but everything that he has commented on, uh,
it is authoritative and significant and,
and important that we search that out.
So, uh, so it's considering all that the Bible says,
not just randomly, but all of the biblical data.
What does it God say about these certain points?
Um, and so the whole Bible's important.
It's not just random. Um, and it's Christian
because we're talking about the whole Bible.
Uh, so as Christians, the whole Bible means
the New Testament and the old, right?
Okay, so we're Christians, meaning
we believe the Old Testament as well as the new.
And, um, so anyway, that's, uh, that's just an important
point that we want to keep in mind
that God has revealed himself
through all the pages of the, of the Bible.
So as we study systematic theology, there's a, uh,
another word that comes up the word doctrine.
Um, and this is, the book is named Bible doctrine.
And so what is a doctrine in general?
A doctrine is just teaching
and instruction is just simply what that means.
Uh, but a specific doctrine is,
you might say it's the result of systematic theology.
It's the result of considering all
that the Bible says about a particular thing you would say.
That thing, when we've distilled down into, we've kinda
considered everything God has said about a subject
that we would say, well, that is a doctrine.
That's what the whole Bible teaches about
that certain thing.
So what, what the Bible teaches about the nature
of God in the sense that he's a trinity, uh,
or about the incarnation of the Lord Jesus
or the deity of Christ, for example.
Uh, these, actually, these aren't words the Bible uses.
Trinity is not in the Bible.
Uh, they weren't, incarnation was not in the Bible.
Um, and,
and the deity of Christ,
at least in the way that we say that.
And so, but these are words that help us to capture
a large amount of content in the Bible
and distill them into words that we can use to communicate
and, uh, and to categorize those things with.
So, so that would be a doctrine.
And, and in this class, and there's major
and minor doctrines, uh, in this class,
predominantly, I've got a list here.
Uh, the doctrines will go through the board of God,
the nature of God, uh, the doctrine of man, uh, the doctrine
of sin, of Christ, of the Holy Spirit, salvation
of the church, the future.
Uh, you can use the big theological terms,
which I'd encourage you, frankly, to get familiar with.
There's bology, theology, anthropology, pharmacology.
There's christology, pneumatology, soteriology,
ecclesiology and eschatology.
And so all the ologies you could want, uh, if you hang
around, that's what we're gonna be talking about.
So, um, anyway, um, you know, Lord willing,
I, I hope that in a class like this, that in some level
and in some way, every single one of us
will encounter some truth about God
that maybe we haven't really thought about
as often or as deeply.
Uh, you might even find as you study the Bible like this,
that it challenges some of the beliefs
that you've already held or maybe that you were raised with.
Uh, if you grew up in church,
you might have a very specific tradition where some of
that gets, you kind of think, Hmm, you know, is
that quite the way it goes?
Or If you didn't grow up in church, then
I guarantee you're gonna have some of that.
And, um, but we'll have that across the board, in fact.
And I wanna encourage you that, uh, that's a good thing.
Like, it's a good thing to reflect on what we believe
and to assess what we believe in light of God's word.
And to let God teach us through his words.
Some of the way, often it gets referred to is that we want
to thank God's thoughts
after him, meaning God's word has been revealed
to us in writing, so we can read it
so that we can understand it.
So we begin to think about the world and life
and who he is in light of what he's already thought.
And he's made that clear to us.
So, so our our authority is God's word.
And, um, not so much our tradition
or, um, or any of that.
So there, you know, we, you can talk about, there's other
forms of, uh, theological study that you can pursue.
There's historical theology.
I've included this in the notes.
Um, that's just kind of looking throughout history,
how has the church thought about this particular thing?
So you could go back like 1800 years.
How did the church view the Lord's supper?
And then, you know, 1,680,
how did the church approach the Lord's supper?
And then in 1905,
how did the church consider the Lord's Supper?
That's historical theology.
Uh, and you can do that on all the different topics.
And so it's a, it's a historical consideration.
There's philosophical theology, which you really don't have
to use the Bible too much, but people do those trying
to use logic and reason.
It's related to the next one.
It can be, uh, which is apologetics, which is, uh,
attempting to defend the Christian faith to unbelievers or,
or to present Christian truth in a way that sort
of argues reliably into an unbelieving world.
And, um, so that's another one. There's ethics, ethics.
It's concerned about questions of how we live now, as we'll.
See, I mean, like, all of theology does
and should have immediate application,
at least at some point into our lives.
But, but the whole realm of ethics has to do with, um,
you know, how implications of, of the truth of God's word.
So like, you might say, family or marriage or,
or issues of like the end of life for abortion,
racial reconciliation, or whatever it might be.
And so the Bible speaks to ethical things,
whether you're a Christian or not, right?
It addresses that. And so that's the idea of ethics.
Now, biblical theology is, uh, you know,
obviously we want all of our theology to be biblical.
I'm saying that what we're doing in this class is biblical,
but as a category, biblical theology just means
that rather than looking at the whole Bible,
you're looking at a part of the Bible.
What is it that Paul teaches?
What is it that the book of Matthew teaches?
What is it that this paragraph teaches? You know?
And so it's thinking what you might call canonically
and the whole canon of the Bible.
Where are we and what exactly is sort of being communicated?
And then, anyway, so that's, we could go on,
but two subsets of that are Old Testament theology
and New Testament theology.
It just means that they're limited to the realm
of the Old Testament or li
or limited to the realm of the New Testament.
So that's, uh, that's some of the other options
that you can pursue in theology.
So anyways, uh, just moving along,
theology studies two primary aspects of God.
We'll talk about a lot more than that,
but fundamentally, um, there's two primary aspects.
So, uh, lemme just get, let me, let's see here.
Who wants to volunteer without knowing
what you're sounding up for?
Anybody, anybody brave? Any courageous souls out there?
Tr everybody know tr I'll just volunteer.
You don't have to get up. Hey, Julie, you don't have
to do anything, honestly.
Um, anybody?
You, you, well, hang on, hang on a second.
Uh, so, so tr somebody tell me about t
Sorry, I, he has great fashion sense, clearly a skater
with Yeah, absolutely.
Wait, what'd you say?
I said he's clearly a skater with a Santa Cruz skater.
I know. Fashion sense. He's a skater. I don't know.
Is that right? Are you a skater?
Just looks like this does my passion since winning out over
Yeah, I was say, but,
but in all seriousness, like, um,
what do we know about tr He's a doctor.
Okay, he's a doctor. It's what you do. What else?
What's that? He's got a missionary card. Okay. Yeah.
What else? Dad? What?
The dad, I'm sorry. He's a dad. Yeah. Okay.
Who's related to, um, I wasn't gonna say he's tall,
but everybody's tall to me, so I don't really know
actually about that.
Um, what else? One more. Church leader.
Church leader, okay. All around Greg Gaff. Okay. Yeah.
So, so what we're describing is things
that are like ways he's like, uh, things you do things, uh,
from the way you dress to what you do for work, um,
people you're related to.
So in the same way in theology,
we're talking about the nature of God, we're talking about
what he's like, who he's related to, uh, things he does,
what's his occupation, um, what he has done.
And so these are all things that we talk about in theology.
So the two main, if you're using the notes, the points are,
uh, we talk about God's being kind of just who he is.
And we talk about his acting.
So who God is and what he does or what he has done
or what he is going to do.
These are all the things that we consider about God.
So, um, three aspects to theology that we'll study here.
Uh, number one, um, I've already said this.
We're talking about Christian theology.
It's Christian, not non-Christian theology.
Um, our focus is Protestant rather than Roman Catholic
or Eastern Orthodox
or some other kind of branch of, uh, Christian
of Christianity, of which there are many.
Um, and so just quickly kind of what that means.
We could talk a lot about this. I don't want
to spend too much time 'cause I don't think we're real.
I think we're all on a similar page to some extent.
Um, but in the Protestant reformation, um,
of which I we're very much a part of that scream
of Christianity, um, the, the idea was, you know,
in the Catholic church it had grown up,
especially in the medieval
or the, the sort of the middle ages, uh,
Catholic church had had grown up where they really,
and they, and they codified this later to where today, the,
the Catholic Church would say,
and we would've a major disagreement over this point.
They would say that the tradition of the church,
the traditional teachings, if you've ever seen it,
they have a, you know, the, I mean, I,
I have nothing against Catechisms for sure, but, um,
but there's, the Catholic Catechism is a very big book.
And, and that's like, that is sort of the case law,
or I dunno if that's the best way to say it, of kind of
what they believe about all the, all the nuances.
And they would say their tradition is equal
to the Bible.
And so you have scripture
and you have tradition, the church tradition on par.
And so we would say tradition actually matters, but,
but we would not say that it's authoritative in the same
way, clearly as the Bible is.
And so in the Protestant Reformation, um,
there's a long story involved,
but the question began to say how, I mean,
scholars were just beginning to go
and read the original writings of Aristotle
and Plato and whoever.
And so they began to say, Hey,
why don't we go read the Bible like in its original Greek
and Hebrew, and began to open the Bible
and read it for themselves, not just in the translated Latin
of a thousand years before.
And, uh, they began to go, huh, you know, read the Bible
and it's a little different, right?
It looks a little different than my tradition.
And, uh, and so anyway,
so the word Protestant literally means, uh,
protest, right?
We protest against some of those things.
And anyway, um, the, the point is that we would say in
that movement, uh, we are the beneficiaries of the idea
of going back to the Bible
and going back to the Bible as our primary source.
And, uh, so we'll see there is a place
for a tradition, um, for sure.
But, but the place
of the Bible being really elevated is God's revealed
word so quickly.
Uh, you know, there are the five Sos
of the Protestant Reformation.
Anybody know 'em? Can you sp 'em off? So s scriptura.
So s scriptura means the word
of God alone, anybody else.
So is Christus Christ alone,
soe faith alone.
So gratia, which is grace alone, which means gift.
It's not a matter of earning anything.
Sola scripture, the Bible alone, um,
and sola de glory for the glory of God alone.
And, um, this has to do with who saves us how
and, and why.
And, uh, and so this is the legacy
of the Protestant reformation.
Likewise, um, we, we would hold to an idea
of this number six on the list, the priesthood
of all believers, which, uh, kind
of talks about the nature of the church.
And, uh, and this is where we would say that we don't have
to have a priest to mediate for us a human, uh,
a currently living, how do I wanna say that?
Um, priest to say, hear our confession and,
and stand between us and God, but we have a mediator.
In fact, we have a human mediator who's not only human,
but he's also fully divine,
and he stands in our place, he mediates for us so
that we can now go directly to God
through the Lord Jesus Christ.
And so there's nothing hindering us.
And so in that sense, we're, we become through the,
the miraculous grace of God in our lives, priests
to God most high, and, and in,
and in that way, we,
we don't need another mediator than the one.
We have the Lord Jesus. And then we also
serve a priestly function in the world through the church,
through, through every believer, God is working and,
and moving and speaking through us
and through our lives to other people.
And so anyway, we would say the priesthood of all believers,
just some of the hallmarks of sort of a Protestant, um,
perspective on theology.
I, I like this. I dunno if you've ever seen, um, John, Wes,
John Wesley's, uh, it's what's called the quadrilateral.
It's this image. Does everybody have a copy
of that or can you see it?
I didn't bring to put it up on the board.
Um, so John Wesley, anybody know John Wesley?
Any good Methodist in here?
I'm not a good one, but I grew up Methodist.
And, uh, so anyway, um, John Wesley actually great.
Like, like I have some complaints about the
Methodist Church for sure.
But in its beginning, John
and Charles Wesley were, were really great, uh, in a lot
of ways, um, had some issues, but don't we all.
Anyway, um, so he was born in 1703.
He was a leader in the first great awakening, uh, founder
of the Methodist movement.
And, um, you know, one of the things that, that they,
that he saw, and
that was a real concern in the first great awakening in the
US was that there were a lot of Christians, uh,
or at least people who claimed to be Christian.
And, but there was no like zeal for God, you know,
there was no like passion for God, no, no love
for God, and they wanted to fix that.
And really, in the first grade awakening you, you really saw
that, like those sort of cold dead knowledge of God and,
and believers kind of a name only really came to life.
And there was just a lot of movement in that regard.
But then what that turned into later on, which is often, uh,
the case, is it became this sort of excess of just sort
of experience,
or it became somewhat untethered from, uh,
of the knowledge of about God.
And it was more about the experience
that people were having.
And so people were having these crazy experiences
of the presence of God.
And, and it sort of took on this.
And so it's kinda like, you know, you drive down the road
and you have danger on all side, right?
You can go off the side on the right,
and then if you're not careful,
you can go off the side on the left.
And so it, that's sort of what they saw happening.
And so John Wesley, kind of
what he called his quadrilateral was, um,
was this sort of an idea right here.
He says, um, so, so you have reason,
tradition and experience, so's reason.
We want to, like we're talking about in this class,
we wanna be reasonable, thoughtful,
and intentional about what we think about God and his work.
We want to be careful and diligent
and like we glorify God in the way we think about who he is
and what he's like and what he's done.
But, but our reason
and our logic is also fallen, right?
We live, we're fallen human beings.
So even our thinking, even as we're sometimes trying
to read God's word, we can have strange notions
or we can be misled.
Like, I mean, Satan himself has quoted the Bible, you know,
it's in the beginning of the book he came to, he even said,
he say, did God really say that?
Right? And so twist God's word, it can happen in our minds,
it can happen in our communities,
it can happen in our hearts or lives.
It's kinda like, I think I've told this story before.
I was a brand new believer and I was reading through,
I think it was the book of Romans,
I can't remember which one it is now, but um, and,
and I was reading along and it said, uh, God has now brought
light and immorality to life through the gospel.
And I thought, man, that doesn't sound right.
And I thought about that, how,
how has God brought immorality to I?
It didn't sound negative, it sounded positive.
I called my pastor, he read it
and he was like, man, I don't know.
That's weird. And then we both realized
that was a bad pastor.
We both realized that I was not reading English properly.
It's not immorality,
it's immortality got very light immortality.
So that just happened. And the way I was in reading,
we both just laughed and we're like, wow.
But he felt worse than I didn't.
And, um, so anyway, so like, you know, we get confused.
Uh, we're just falling.
Um, sometimes it's 'cause we're just are,
and we're the victim of that.
Sometimes it's because in our nature
we don't like God's word.
We don't like, like there's things in us that resist that.
I don't wanna believe that. I don't want to do that, right?
And, uh, and so anyway, so there's reason, um, it's also tra
and so that's important,
but there's some issues whether there's tradition.
We've already talked about some of the issues
with tradition, but here's one
of the positive things about tradition, uh,
whether it's in our church or it's in our church history,
it's that, you know, like, believe it
or not, like you're just not the first Christian
who's ever walked on the planet.
You know? And I mean, like, so we, there's a lot
of people in this room, but you, like, if we had in a room,
every Christian that has ever lived since 2000 years ago,
we have an awful lot of people who've been
thinking about God's word.
And sometimes, you know, it's what CS Lewis calls
chronological snobbery.
Sometimes we, we think, well, we,
we understand better than everybody else.
You know, I don't know what was wrong with those guys.
Well, one day people will think that about us.
You know, what was wrong with those guys?
And, uh, some of it they'll be
right, some of they'll be wrong.
But, um, but so just the idea that,
that we really don't have to think about God's word alone.
We have one another. We have believers who've gone
before us for generations.
And so tradition is valuable,
but if it's all you've got, then, uh,
then you have this limited, what you might
call leftover manna.
You know, the man would go bad in the wilderness.
And, and it's like, you know, for this generation, how's,
how are we, you know, understanding God's word
and communicating that in the world anyway?
So, uh, the tradition can be dead, it can be vital.
Uh, it's just like institutions.
They can be, uh, really keepers of the flame
or they can really, uh, you know, be a huge impediment.
So anyway, there's that. There's also experience.
You know, we sometimes when we say, man,
if I experience, were you getting my attention?
No. Where are we at on time?
Just, it helps me 6 58 right now. Okay.
Um, so our experience, like experience is important,
but believe it or not, experience itself is fallible, right?
Especially when we're talking about this subjective
nature of our feelings.
Um, you know, you have a dream or,
or you, you have an emotion
and you can feel like, like, is that from God?
Or what does that mean?
And, and there's just not concrete answers to that.
And sometimes God moves subjectively in our hearts,
and sometimes he's not.
Sometimes it's just the pizza from the night before, right?
And it's like, and so our, our, our experience
and our emotions, they need to be taught by God's word.
They need to be interpreted by God's word.
They're not enough in and of themselves.
So anyway, so that was just kind of what Wesley was trying
to capture is he saw people going on both sides in their
experience, their tradition with the logic.
Um, I guess it was a three sided road, which is different.
But anyway, um,
so I like that, and I think that's important.
So the third aspect here is, uh,
within Protestantism Protestant theology, uh, we hold
what would be called an evangelical theology.
Now, I know that like evangelicalism sort
of in the media kind of has a bad rap today.
And, and I don't know where you are on all that.
All that means is historically speaking, what it meant
to be an evangelical Christian is across
denominational lines.
Do you believe that the Bible's true?
And the Jesus Christ is the only way to know God and um,
and believe in the virgin birth
and the resurrection and all that?
That's sort of all I meant.
And, and so those four primary categories
or characteristics of historic evangelical Protestantism,
which is conversion is faith
and action, uh, trustworthiness and authority of the Bible
and the centrality of the cross.
So conversion is this just means that we believe
that there are no grandchildren in the family of God,
that you have to be born again, right?
If that's, if you're raised in a Christian
family, that that's unique.
Like in fact, I love boring testimonies.
Like I want people to, kids
to grow up all they ever knew was the truth of God's word.
And go, yeah, I'm a sinner in need of a savior,
and I believe that, and he's changed my life,
but it didn't take me, you know, going down every road.
And, uh, but there we also believe
that some people didn't grow up that way, or,
or some people abandoned that road.
And there's dramatic, you know, problems
that can come in our lives
and all that dramatically changes by the grace of God.
We believe you have to believe and be born again.
And, uh, so you have to trust in Christ,
uh, faith in action.
Um, just that our faith affects our lives.
It ought to be demonstrated, um, by us reaching out
to the world and even loving the people around us,
even serving sacrificially, um, the trustworthiness
and authority of the Bible.
Um, just where the authority of God's word is central
and reliable.
And so, like, we'd rather say, like the Bible says,
let God be true in every man a liar.
Or sort of the idea of sometimes if, like,
if I'm reading the Bible and I think I'm not sure
that I like what I'm reading,
the problem's probably with me, right?
And not the Bible. And so the idea is how do we humbly
walk in light of God's word and know
and believe what God has said to be true?
Um, and then finally the centrality of the cross
and the resurrection of Jesus, that
that's the center of our faith.
So it makes us Christians
and we believe the Christ is who the Bible says he is.
He's ruling in reigning now he's coming again in glory.
And, uh, we have to, uh, we have to know him.
So, um, so when it comes to doctrinal issues, though,
I'm gonna, there, there's a lot to cover.
There's even a lot of verses here.
We're definitely not gonna read.
So you might look these up as you go along.
Um, you may even think of others as well.
Feel free to write those down.
Um, so there are primary and secondary doctrines.
There's major and minor doctrines, and, um,
and so, you know, not everything is equally
important, right?
So we would say everything in God's word is important,
but it's important that we understand that not everything
is equally important.
So I love this. We'll talk about it more, uh, later.
At some point, at least if you're in the seminary class,
we will, they read an article on this,
but Al Moler had this article years ago called
Theological Triage.
And, um, and so triage, right?
Actually I was, uh, just revisiting this kind of came out
of at least the, the theology.
This sort of comes out of a, a wartime scenario.
Um, I can't remember what the situation was,
but there was, um, there was a, a war,
maybe I'm thinking it was even somewhere in Europe where,
where everyone that came in injured, didn't matter
what their injury was,
that you got treated in chronological order.
And so if you had a, you lost a fingernail, you got treated
before the guy with the head wound, right?
And so they began to triage that.
You could probably tell us more, give a better summary.
So if you want to clean, clean this up, talk
to t It's in that book.
Yeah, it's in the book. Okay, yeah, there you go.
Anyway, so, but the main point is that we try
to order things by importance.
And, um, and so kind of, if you've heard
of fundamentalism being kind of a bad word,
like I would say I'm a fundamentalist in the sense
that I believe in the fundamentals of the faith,
but kind of as a movement, it kind of had a tendency
to make everything equally important.
And so, uh, so everything's fighting worse.
That's why it's in the book, right?
Finding the right hills to die.
There are hills to die on, but it's not every single hill.
So anyway, it says first order, second order, third order,
first order doctrines.
Like a year ago, I guess it was, you know, John Todd on the,
uh, Todd on the first things, it's sort of this idea, is
that what he, that's what the name was, right?
Um, and so, so first order, if you deny this,
you're basically not a Christian question of the authority
of the Bible, the deity of Christ, the nature
of the trinity, and so on.
Big rocks, the big rocks, there you go.
And so the smaller rocks, the second order doctrines, uh,
you can recognize, uh, that this person's a Christian all,
even though few maybe don't do church together, right?
We, we view the Lord's suffer real differently,
or we baptize some baptize babies and some don't,
or whatever it is.
You know, there's different, different things,
but genuine Christians disagree on them.
And the third order doctrines, it's just,
we just agree to disagree.
This could be your timing of, you know,
how you view the end times your eschatology, uh,
your views on predestination in a granular manner.
Um, what, what you think about the methylene, right?
Hey, we can all go to church together if you've got a
different opinion about the methylene.
And, um, so the historic way of talking about this
is this saying, and I'd encourage you
to get familiar with it if you're not.
It says in essentials, it's first order, doctrines unity.
So what it means to be a Christian in
non-essentials, there's liberty.
And then in all things there's charity for love.
And so graciousness towards one another, okay?
So, uh, mystery paradox, contradictions and tension.
God is mysterious is the word.
And so we go back to Deuteronomy 29, 29.
There are mysteries. In fact, when you read,
especially the New Testament,
I'd encourage you pay attention
to when you encounter the word mystery.
This is a word that Martin Lutheran loved,
like Lutherans love this.
I got any Lutherans in the room.
They talk a lot about mystery
because that it's actually like an important word in the
Bible, uh, in the New Testament.
And what Paul, typically, when he's using that word,
what he means is, here's a thing that we didn't know
until God made it known, especially in regard to the nature
of Christ and the gospel.
That's, and that's his mystery that was hidden
for the ages past, but now has been made known, right?
So anyway, so, but, but there are other mysteries.
Deuteronomy 29, the secret things belong
to the Lord our God, but the things revealed,
the mysteries explained, belonged to us.
So there's contradictions that we can have,
and we don't, we don't want contradictions,
we don't like contradictions.
This is where things actually,
two things literally cannot be true at the same time, right?
The cat is not a dog.
You can't be walking the dog and not be walking the dog.
At the same time. A circle is not a triangle,
and they can't be true at the same time.
And so in the Bible, there is never a contradiction.
If you listen to media, if you, if you have ever been
to a university, they, everybody's ready to tell you
how many contradictions are in the Bible.
There's actually no true contradictions in the Bible.
What, what follows is this word, there are
what you would call a paradox.
There are things that might seem to be contradictory,
but they're not so like, like it's the word, uh, seemingly
or uh, like have you ever, what's the phrase, thinking
of paradoxes you have sometimes we'll say you can have
more with less.
You ever heard that? What's happening?
How can you have more with less?
Sounds like a contradiction,
but yet we put it on bumper stickers,
and at least somebody did somewhere.
What's it mean you can have a full life, even if you get rid
of all your toys, um,
and maybe even you'd be happier if you declutter, right?
That's kind of what that means. Um, and so anyway, think or,
or you might say, say theologically, uh, you know,
often we would say, you even see the, the,
the characters in the Bible wrestle with this.
Um, it, see, I, it seems like
God is not in control, but he is.
And that's actually paradox we often wrestle
with at the level of our lives.
And so anyway, so paradox is not contradiction.
Um, but those are important distinctions.
Um, Isaiah 55, 8, my ways are above your ways,
and my thoughts are above your thoughts, says the Lord.
So it means if you're struggling to get your mind
around something that's true about God, then like,
don't be discouraged.
It doesn't mean there's not an answer.
It doesn't mean you'll be forever stumped by that,
but it does mean that sometimes it can be
a little hard to grasp.
So we want to persevere in that.
Um, so it, it's kinda like,
so it's this tension, okay?
Like there's another, uh,
how are we doing on time?
7 0 9. Oh, okay.
You're doing better than, okay, that's good to know.
Alright, So here's a huge point of tension.
You can fall off this way, you can fall off this way,
or you can sort of balance
In these tensions.
So for example, uh, we say Jesus Christ
is fully God and fully man.
Anybody here completely understand that, okay?
But we would say that's what the Bible teaches.
It actually makes sense if we follow the logic
of the Bible and we hold that to be true.
But it's sometimes hard to get your mind around, uh,
we believe what we believe about the Bible.
We say it is the word of God,
but we also say it was literally written by men
and so well, which isn't right?
So it's not a contradiction.
There's some mystery, there's some
paradox and there's tension.
Uh, if you, so, just like Christ, you can say, you know,
Jesus is only God.
There's no way he's a man.
Well, then we lose all that biblical teaching and,
and you leave Christianity in the same way.
You say the Bible is only the word of man.
Well, you clearly lose Christianity.
Um, and so, but you have to hold the two together,
or, uh, you might say with salvation, um, you know,
we see in the Bible talks about God chooses his people on
the one hand, and then on the other hand,
we're told we have to trust them.
And so we choose God, he chooses us, right?
There's paradox that goes along.
So, um, we say you can't lose your salvation, absolutely,
but we're also told we have to persevere in the faith.
And so we've got to continue.
Uh, some of the evidence of God's grace in our life is
that he keeps us.
But it looks like me going, you know what, today
I'm gonna read my Bible, I'm gonna trust God,
I'm gonna fellowship with you.
I'm gonna repent.
When I've sinned, I'm gonna, you know, keep going.
And by God's grace we do it.
So anyway, attention paradox, all that.
And, and so what it, what it ought to do is, uh, remind us
that we're really dependent on God.
And so we learn to grow best when we stay humble
before the Lord and we're dependent on him.
And, um, and so it, it should help, help us to do that.
Um, this quote by this guy, Robert Fugate
says, where biblically sound, systematic theology is absent,
A vacuum does not remain.
Unbiblical theology replaces a biblical theology.
In its absence. Systematic theology cannot be avoided.
It is never a question of theology or no theology.
It is always a question of what theology, biblical theology
or unbiblical theology.
Theology is an inescapable concept.
Everyone has a theology, whether it's good
or bad, consistent or inconsistent.
Everyone is a theologian. Alright?
So welcome to theology class
where you guys have all been anointed theologians.
You actually walked in the door as theologians
because if you've ever thought about God,
you're having theological thoughts.
So you might as well just own it and embrace it
and begin to do it well,
because all of us at times, we have our weak points
and we want to grow and change,
and we need, need God's grace to do so.
Um, okay, so two main themes we emphasize, uh,
number one here, truth and life.
It means God's word, what he's revealed,
it's ultimate and it matters.
This is universal for us
and everyone around the planet throughout
history and in the future.
And then secondarily, it has to do with life.
It's that we live our lives in light of the truth
of God's word.
And that way we understand that everything is theological.
Okay? So 10 reasons why we should study systematic theology.
It addresses the most important subject in the universe,
and that is that it's talking about God himself.
And God, as we've seen Deuteronomy 29 29, again, God has
made himself known.
And so God's word is true, it's available,
and we need to avail ourselves of those truths.
So, um, in fact, uh, systematic theology, it,
it probably still referred to in some ways this way,
but it, it used to be known as sort of, I don't remember
what the saying was, but kind of the, the crown jewel of,
uh, of learning.
So you would, you would learn history and philosophy
and science, and then you would tie all that truth together
in light of the nature of God and who he is.
And so theology is sort of the crown jewel on top
of knowledge, all knowledge.
Seven 15. Thank you sir.
It's like break train coming through.
There we are done at seven 30, right? Yeah.
Okay, so, um, there's a reason I'm tracking time.
A I'm terrible at tracking time
and BI have something we're doing a minute.
Um, okay, so let me go through this quickly.
Uh, we need to study theology like this for obedience.
We need to do so for two main obedience in two ways, right?
There's two things God, us revealed
that should guide our whole lives.
We call it the great commandment
and the great commission, the great commandment says what?
You should love the Lord your God with all your heart, soul,
mind and strength.
Second one, similar. Love your neighbor as yourself.
It's where practical implication,
application of love for God.
And so in part love for God, you, you called the love God
with all our minds we think of.
We also also talk about,
often talk about love God with all our hearts.
And we wanna stir our emotions, which is right,
but we also need to stir our minds
and love God with all of our minds.
Uh, um, Read these,
read these quotes later if you like.
I want to keep moving. It's just the, it's kind
of the old analogy of the freight train.
Um, you, you guys ever seen the analogy of the train
where the engine is the truth
and it's pulling the freight of, oh,
your other thought will, will,
and thoughts will and emotion.
And so the feel your feelings matter.
I don't want to neglect that, but it's,
but they're in the caboose, right?
They're, they're, they're carriage.
They're, uh, they're being pulled along.
They ought to be pulled. So they ought to be there.
We ought to have our hearts stirred towards God.
We ought to have love for God and passion for God,
but it is brought along by the steam engine
of God's truth and God's word.
Okay? So love for God with all
of our heart, soul, mind, and strength.
The second way we obey God is
through obeying the Great Commission, uh, Matthew 28 18.
Hopefully you're very familiar with this.
Uh, it's the call to go out into the world
and as we go to do what?
To make disciples of all nations, teaching them everything
that he has taught.
Okay, well, if you don't know what that is,
you don't understand it, you're gonna be, it's gonna be hard
to communicate to other people.
It's gonna be hard to teach other people if you don't have
some measure of understanding for yourself.
Um,
Okay, I'll move on.
Um, theology empowers us to enjoy God number four
in greater ways, the Westminster Confession of Faith.
A famous, uh, historical statement of faith says
that she begins, the chief end of man is to glorify God
and to enjoy him forever.
And I love how John Piper turns this to say, the chief end
of man is to glorify God by enjoying him forever.
If you don't know who God is
and what he's like, it's gonna be real hard
to enjoy him for who he is.
It's kinda like somebody maybe you've studied,
but you've never actually been around.
It's, it is somebody you kind of know some facts about, uh,
kind of your, your, your baseball crush or,
or whoever it might be, you know, all the stats
versus like the person you're married to
that you know really well.
So, um, alright
Man, I'm behind time.
Lemme do this. What's that?
All right, so time again, gimme time, give 18. Okay.
Um, theology will be a foundation in suffering
as we understand what God's revealed about the world.
Think about James who said in chapter one, counter All joy,
my brothers all joy.
Think about it this way.
When you suffer trials of various kind,
or Joe who said, naked, I came from my mother's womb,
naked all apart, the Lord gave,
the Lord takes away, has taken away.
Blessed be the name of the Lord. Uh, James was martyred.
Joe famously suffered, and yet
because of their knowledge of God, both about him
and their experience with him kept them.
And in the midst of time, uh, trial and struggle.
So we worshiped through tears
and we're re we're rooted for the storms.
It's like the anchor to our soul up here.
The drift in the sea of the world,
the anchor is gonna be the truth of God's word.
Uh, theology unifies Christians.
Number six, it, uh, protects the church.
Number seven, um, you know, there's a lot
of competing ideas out there.
Liberal theology, which is sort of changes words
to mean things that they don't really mean.
Um, well, so like you,
the classic one is we believe in the resurrection.
Dang. It's like the trumpet. Yeah.
Okay, so remind me, what time is that morning? 20. 20.
Okay, I got five minutes.
Um, okay, so, uh,
I didn't know the train was gonna be going off,
but I'm good.
I'm good. I asked for this actually.
Uh, Okay.
Uh, causes, there's causes for error.
It's when we obscure misuse the Bible.
Uh, Satan said, did God really say this? We question that.
Personal sin actually stands in the way. Believe it or not.
Rightly understanding God's word can be affected
by your personal sin.
And I'm just pulling the finger like,
like I live this, right?
So in, in the struggles I have where I struggle in my life,
where I don't walk with God will in like, that,
can actually affect what we believe, you know?
'cause it's a man, I don't wanna believe this or,
or it causes me like Adam and E were running high, right?
And so it's, we, we walk in the light
and, um, anyway, so it can stand in our way.
Uh, number eight, theology assists us in sharing our faith,
as we've seen with non-Christians.
Uh, number nine, it spurs our sanctification and growth.
Um, number 10, it brings glory to God.
We've already talked about this.
Um, okay, so how do we study? How do we study theology?
When we do so with prayer?
We, we do so dependently, praying on to God would help us
and give us wisdom and insight, just like David,
like I quoted earlier, said,
open my eyes that I would see this.
So what David's acknowledging is
that it's like his eyes are closed.
There's things he doesn't see, that he doesn't like,
that he doesn't understand.
And he's asking God, in my blindness
or in my willfully closed eyes to who you are,
would you please open my eyes?
Would you help me to see something that I don't?
And, uh, and so we pray, we pray that God would help us and,
and, and help overcome all of our limitations.
Uh, as I said earlier, we do so with humility.
And, um, and humility is, uh, the,
the Bible says in multiple places, God
actively opposes the proud.
And he gives grace to who? Humble.
He gives grace to the humble.
So we wanna walk into humility and dependence on God.
Uh, so generally speaking, it's sort of like
what we've talked about already.
Um, three different levels at which we should hold
certain theological beliefs.
Uh, there's convictions, persuasions, and opinions. Okay?
There's top tier enc, closed handed issues.
This is kind of back, I should have put this back in the
other convictions, persuasions and opinions.
Um, sometimes we're real excited about our opinions
and we're actually confused.
Or it's actually, just so you know, it, there's,
it's not wrong to have like an opinion
about something that's unclear.
I got all kinds of opinions. Like even do you see this?
Do you see Paul do this? I think it's the first Corinthians.
He's talking about celibacy
and he says, Hey, in my opinion, that's the best thing.
'cause I mean, look at all the ministry I can do,
but he doesn't say, he says, that's me.
That's not the Lord, you know?
Um, okay, uh, I will
send you the rest of the answers here.
What's the top 2, 3, 2, 3. Oh, I got two minutes.
Number three is reason and logic or reason.
We wanna be, uh, we study with reason and logic.
We're thoughtful, like we've talked about.
We wanna do with other Christians, um, with, with the help
of Christians throughout church history, as we've seen
by collecting and understanding all the relevant passages in
the Bible, not just kind of cherry, cherry picking the ones
that seem to apply.
Number seven, we're rejoicing.
We, we do so with rejoicing and praise
and this is where I wanna land the plane.
Okay? Would somebody in your Bible please read Psalm
1 19, 1 62,
Psalm
1 19, 1 62 44
what?
24 minutes. Oh, oh, for real.
Oh, okay, well go for it. What was
It? Psalm one 16,
Psalm one nineteen, one hundred and sixty two.
If I wrote this down correctly,
I rejoice your word like one dup finds
Great spoil.
Okay, great spoil.
Mike, would you be happy if you felt
like this huge treasure?
Anybody? Okay.
I would, I mean, Elise,
but if I knew nobody was gonna claim it, uh, it's awesome.
Okay, so in God's word, you have found a great spoil. Okay?
Um, JJI Packer, he says, theology is doxology.
And this is where just I want to end here.
He says, uh, it's the idea
that we don't wanna just be informed about God.
We wanna be transformed in our lives.
We want to not only know about God, we want to know him
and theology and doxology, like you see this in Romans 11
and wrote it in there, Paul, but talking about theology.
And he ends with this huge crescendo of praise.
And he says, oh, the depths of the riches
and wisdom of God, he just begins to respond to God's word.
So here's what I wanna do, and we won't do it every night,
probably maybe, but uh, I want to end with a song.
If you guys, uh, if we're up, up,
out on time, you can go if you got to.
But ask Nick to, uh, to lead us in a song.
Make sure you signed up.
The sheets are up here on that table.
It maybe a song, you know,
if you guys wanna pass this around.
And so, uh, I just want, I asked Nick to, uh,
to lead us in the song is this, uh, you may know it.
It's called Behold Our God in, uh, Isaiah 40 is
what the Prophet said, he said,
or the Lord said, get up on a high mountain
and say to my people, say, behold your God.
And what he meant by that is like, we ought to look long
and hard at the beauty and the glory of God.
And that's our goal. And so we wanna send you so
The ocean
rises to
the
Lord.
Can
God
One more time
seated on
Can Compare.
Come let us adore
Mighty God. We thank
you for tonight. We thank you for meeting with us.
Even as we sing these songs, as we begin to just
ly think your thoughts and consider you
and bask in the glory of who you are.
I pray that you would help us to do that in truth
that in our minds and in our hearts
and in our lives, that we would know you
and that we'd be changed by you.
And we reflect that rightly into the world.
God, we love you and we thank you in Jesus name. Amen.
Alright, thank you. Time's
Up.
Oh, if you have it, please sign up. Thank you Nick.
Be my friend. Mark. That's right. Oh, hey.
No, this is, ah,
so is that for the Bible option or for the
Got your
question?
Yeah, go.
Um, hey, what's your name? Kevin. Kevin.
Mark's go. You got signed up.
So this is,
so it's like
the problem.
So
you ever apply
how, how c
So
sometimes I think I'll read over this
and I'll just send get back to you.
That's Yeah, think about it a little bit.
And so, but I do have to
over the, I get credit
and so anyway, so I got my undergrad
as heavy writing.
It's been a while. Been working. Our kids are,
I have
Michelle so much.
Yeah, appreciate. See you later. Later.
You all in, all in all you back all in. Okay, good.
From this is Alex Caro.
Oh, Dan Almost. Yeah. Yeah.
He wore this in the championship parade.
I was like, I'll you for that.
So he sold it on his website
and I was like,
heck no.
Here dude.
I brought mini
like, what you doing with that?
Like, what do you think I got a Yeah, you terrible.
This fall gonna cut
and just remember the good times.
I'll if there's one. Yeah. Yeah.
I mean like
check what's your Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, uh, so just run check because I wasn't going to
but like looking at the, uh, looking at the schedule,
I'm done here
with my other two classes.
Okay. I mean, all I'm doing get all I'm doing.
I love, all I'm doing is I'm just giving you guys a chance
to say, uh, what about just going
everything?
No, honestly say, how are you?
If you have a question, good.
Grab that to take nothing rebel.
So if y'all wanna hung up real
quick, we can do it real quick.
You guys got a minute right here?
Or do you got a I don't wanna
be on, I don't wanna be on camera.
You better go. You have to.
Yeah, I don't, additional project don't
that you have to do for the class.
We got, we gotta do a project, get up
recording.
If I was in front of room thousand people,
recording it to the camera is weird to me.
I can't get over it. I started, I don't want
to listen to myself talk.
Yeah, yeah. I started.